name is Glenn my name is bill and who
here likes vacation I do but it's tough
to take vacation when you only have five
days a lot of the entire year you know
what we're gonna do a little magic here
would you say if we took those five days
we took those five days and we
abra-cadaver made up change it can
happen if you believe in the program
we're talking about we're talking about
a program who wants to book a vacation
no one right oh who wants to think about
where they're going who wants to call up
a hotel go online like a lot of hassle
to me
exactly it is a lot of hassle but not
anymore if you want ten days all you
have to do is vacation at one of three
resorts that we have predetermined for
short like a resort resort it's a resort
in the greater Tampa metropolitan area
yeah and they are so nice how about a
place called Casa Laguna here in Tampa
guys it is so beautiful you got to see
this place you are just a short tram
ride away from the beach how can we
possibly afford this on a cop's salary
well that's the thing
what we do is we go like this what are
we talking about right here guys we're
talking about Tupperware's yeah all you
got to do is sell over $50 of Tupperware
to three to five friends every week for
the next six months and then you qualify
for the package easy what was your
favorite time in your life when you had
sleepover to the friends gather right
well we are gonna give you a bonafide
dorm room experience because you're
gonna be sharing this condo with up to
seven different people and some of them
the beauty of it you don't even know him
so you make new friends
that's good people
talk about security to every window has
bars on them you were protected you're
not gonna have to worry about your stuff
getting stolen and if you're afraid of
other things that might happen at the
beach such as shark attacks did you know
that the occurrence of a shark attack
the odds of that happening are so
minuscule to almost be negligible it's
so negligible it makes me wonder why you
even brought it up well we have to bring
it up by law so we get 10 knots in an
all-inclusive resort to rise of a tram a
job
mandatory lectures and all we have to do
is sell $12,000 worth of top of ways I'm
going to the Tampa area yeah we need an
investment from you for the top where
you're gonna put some money out and then
you're gonna get that money back yeah
come outside
to our van and we are going to give
[Applause]
you